(Dan) So, Rato, what have
we learned in this lesson?
(Rato) Well, I learned that I do not want
to write databases and content providers.
What did you learn in this lesson?
(Dan) Well, JUnit tests are awesome,
and building the back end framework
of our apps is the most glorious of work.
It's an absolutely vital part
of creating a robust app
with a great user experience.
(Rato) I also learned that Dan
cannot do an English accent.
Fortunately, you can get ready
to welcome back Katherine for lesson five
where we'll shatter
our activity into fragments,
use our content providers
to populate more complex UIs,
and build layouts that work as well
on tablet's as they do on phones.
(Dan) Which seems like
a convenient segueway
into the history and evolution
of Android hardware.